à partir du 11 mai le premier ministre a
appelé les français à éviter autant que
possible tout déplacement hors de son
département il sera néanmoins possible
de se déplacer sans motif familial ou
professionnel impérieux uniquement si la
distance parcourue ne dépassent pas les
100 km la vie des français sera donc
différente en zone rouge en zone verte
ou en zone jaune alors assistons à la
mise en place de petites frontières dans
le pays c'est l'objet de notre face à
face et pour en débattre alexis bachelet
conseiller municipal de la ville de
colombes et laurent jacot bélie porte
parole du rassemblement national
messieurs bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoints en direct sur rt france alors
finalement l'instauration de ces
différentes zones dans le pays est ce
que pour vous on peut comparer cela
cette stratégie à la mise en place de
petites frontières à l'intérieur du pays
laurent jacobellis
oui c'est un peu le cas c'est à dire que
le gouvernement a pris une décision qui
est de décliner étape par étape zone à
moins de risques
après zone à moindre risque c'est qu'ils
nous paraît être une bonne solution même
si dans les faits il va falloir nous
expliquer comment quand on travaille
dans un département vert ont pas dans un
conte habite dans un département où l'on
fait etc etc mais ça valide l'idée que
l'importation du virus par un individu
infecté est possible d'un département à
l'autre d'une zone de 100 km à une autre
et bien évidemment d'un pays à l'autre
et c'est david la limite de la logique
du gouvernement c'est à dire que il
ils appliquent des frontières à
l'intérieur de la france mais
malheureusement il refuse de les
appliquer à l'extérieur est ce que vous
savez que cet après midi et ce soir ont
atterri à roissy des avions provenant
des états unis
dezeen qui d'abou dhabi de rome de rome
est d'abidjan
aucun contrôle sanitaire pour aucun des
passagers
et si parmi eux arrivent des passagers
avec le
et russes avec une nouvelle forme de
virus et qui peuvent eux entrer
librement à roissy comment on pourra
expliquer à des français que eux ne
peuvent pas circuler librement
les français sont prêts à faire cet
effort mais ils sont prêts à le faire si
l'effort est national logique est
appliquée aussi aux frontières de notre
territoire alors alexis bachelet ce que
vous vous comprenez ce paradoxe qui a
voulu souligner laurent jacot bélier à
savoir on n'a pas fermé les frontières
nationales
mais aujourd'hui au fond on empêche les
français de se déplacer à l'intérieur du
péri du pays
illogique donc pour vous le rend
jacomelli qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alexis bachelet je crois que c'est
difficile de raisonner de la manière jeu
par analogie entre des frontières
nationales
est ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui c'est à dire un maintien du
confinement mais avec progressivement un
retour de la de la circulation avec des
règles extrêmement extrêmement je dirais
précise et e et différenciés en fonction
du territoire national c'est évident que
à partir du moment où on a des
territoires qui sont moins touchés que
d'autres
c'est assez logiquement que le
gouvernement essaye d'établir de
rétablir un mode de fonctionnement plus
souple que dans d'autres territoires qui
bien sont maintenus dans un confinement
plus plus strict plus rigide
parce que la circulation du virus est
encore relativement importante
donc moi ça ne me choque pas qu'on soit
dans cette logique là peut-être que ce
qui est étonnant et là je donnerais à ta
à laurent jacot berry de son
raisonnement c'est que il aurait
peut-être fallu fermer les frontières
nationales avant c'est vrai que dès que
on a su qu'une épidémie se propager en
chine
il aurait fallu sans doute prendre des
mesures d'abord fermer les voies
aériennes et ensuite probablement
rétablir des contrôles aux frontières et
fermé les frontières à partir du moment
où il était avéré que l'épidémie
ne respectait pas ces dites frontières
et qu'elle était en train de circuler
non seulement à travers la chine met
ensuite en europe l'italie pays voisins
et donc je pense que le gouvernement
français
et j'ai pas forcément les clés pour
comprendre cette décision a tardé à
fermer les frontières et il est
évidemment logique aujourd'hui qu'on
soit dans un mode de déconfinement par
territoire parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de maintenir tout le monde au
même degré de confinement compte tenu du
fait que dans certains territoires le
virus est très peu présent ou quasiment
absent alors langeac obélie la
différence de vie des français dans
chacune des régions a forcément être
être différente en fonction qu'il soit
en jaune rouge ou en zone verte
est ce que cette situation selon vous
peut engendrer des crispations dans le
dans le pays qu'elles soient sociales ou
économiques
oui je crois que les français et ils
l'ont montré au cours des dernières
semaines sont prêts à faire des
sacrifices ils le font avec bonne
volonté plutôt naturellement même s'il
ya des inconvénients de leur vie de tous
les jours mais il accepte de remplir une
attestation pour aller faire leurs
courses ou aller à la pharmacie
ils ont le choix du jeu globalement cet
effort ils ne le feront une continueront
à le faire si et seulement si toutes les
conditions sont remplies pour que ces
efforts soient utiles oui on n'acceptera
dans les zones rouges de faire plus
d'efforts que dans les zones vers mai à
lausanne devait atteindre mais à une
seule condition c'est que le
gouvernement soit à la hauteur des
enjeux et ce qui fait un peu peur c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'il a fixé une
date le 11 mai comme un totem et qu'il
veut derrière que l'intendance suive
mais ce dont on s'est aperçu en france
malheureusement avec cette équipe là
c'est que la tendance ne suivait pas or
est-ce qu'il y aura assez de masquer le
11 mai rien n'est moins sûr
est ce qu'on aura assez de test pour
tester tout le monde notamment ceux qui
vont travailler
rien n'est moins sûr est-ce qu'on va
continuer à s'entêter à vouloir ouvrir
les écoles à leur conseille maintenant
que probablement le coc vide a un effet
sur les plus jeunes qui peut être très
grave
bref les français sont prêts à faire des
efforts mais ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que ceux qui doivent aller soutenir qui
doit créer les conditions de réussite de
l'effort eux ne sont pas à la hauteur
manque aux français on l'a vu à l'aise
avec les masses et les infantilise donc
il ya beaucoup à craindre et vous parler
d'économie moi je suis dans les bouches
du rhône
il ya un certain nombre de restaurateurs
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
vivent du tourisme
aujourd'hui notre département est classé
en zone orange ils n'ont aucune date de
sortie de crise
donc ils ne savent pas à quelle sauce
ils vont être mangés le 11 mai puis
ensuite avant l'été vous comprenez bien
que ce n'est pas possible de maintenir
une activité en l'état donc il y à un
manque de logistique un manque de
préparation et un manque de
planification
les français font un effort il accepte
les conséquence il voulait montrer ils
sont pour la plupart exemplaire mais
l'encadrement
malheureusement ne suit pas alexis
bachelet est ce que dans votre
département vous êtes dans les
hauts-de-seine les français ne pourrait
pas jouer le jeu
si finalement et bien il n'y avait pas
de règles assez clair alors alexis
bachelet peu de petits problèmes
techniques qui nous a quittés en
attendant qu'il revienne je me tourne
vers vous laurent jacobellis donc vous
lisiez des français qui ne pourraient
voile alors alexis bachelet qui a un
problème technique donc des français qui
ne joueraient pas le jeu hein vous
dizier j'ai pas dit ça et j'ai dit qu'on
prend un risque
pour l'instant je joue exemple aryenne
de manière exemplaire le jeu pour la
plupart voilà alors le voilà alexis
bachelet est revenu avec nous alors est
ce que vous craignez alexis d'acheter
dans votre département
que des français finalement s'ils n'ont
pas une vision suffisamment claire ne
respectent pas les consignes prévu par
le gouvernement bat d'abord je pense
qu'il faut quand même saluer globalement
le civisme et le sens de responsabilité
de nos compatriotes qui quasiment dès le
début du confinement ont respecté les
consignes gouvernementales et avant même
d'être confiné avait commencé à
respecter les gestes barrière
aujourd'hui effectivement la durée du
confinement rend cette situation de plus
en plus inconfortable
il faut que le gouvernement soit le plus
clair possible dans les décisions qui
seront prises notamment effectivement en
direction des activités économiques qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt et
extrêmement touchées dont on craint
d'ailleurs pour certaines activités
qu'elle soit vraiment en danger et c'est
vrai que le tourisme dans ces
activités-là fait partie des activités
qui sont gravement empêcher contrainte
avec évidemment toute la partie
restauration hôtellerie bon levier au
moins ils continuent à partir du moment
où le gouvernement ne sait pas comment
l'épidémie va continuer à vivre sa vie
edouard philippe lavil a été
relativement clair là dessus
il va falloir qu'on vivent avec le virus
donc ça veut dire que vivre avec ça ne
sera pas revenir à la situation d'avant
le confinement
ça sera continuer à vivre avec des
contraintes extrêmement que forte plus
forte dans certains territoires plus
fort sur certaines activités et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut que le
gouvernement communique de manière
extrêmement régulière extrêmement clair
au fur et à mesure que la situation
évoluera avec des indicateurs pour
pouvoir essayer de donner une plus
grande visibilité non seulement aux
activités économiques mais également à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes qui
aujourd'hui c'est vrai sont plongés dans
l'antre dans l'anxiété est dans le doute
parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
visibilité sur la manière dont les
prochaines semaines vont se dérouler il
nous reste quelques secondes laurent
jacot billy pour conclure on sait que le
gouvernement compte beaucoup sur sur les
les
les élus locaux est-ce qu'on va pas
faire des petits états dans l'état
finalement où chacun va gérer avec ses
moyens à sa manière sur son territoire
la situation encore heureux que le
dévouement de beaucoup d'élus locaux est
venu se substituer à la compétence et à
la préparation du gouvernement il
faudrait pas d'ailleurs que monsieur
edouard philippe ou que le président de
la république qui commencent à
comprendre que leurs mensonges du début
pourrait leur revenir en effet boomerang
après la fin de la crise essaye de faire
porter toutes les responsabilités aux
maires en leur demandant de protéger nos
concitoyens se leur en donner les moyens
vous savez on sortira de cette crise du
coronavirus qu'effectivement si tout le
monde joue le jeu d'abord le
gouvernement
il faut protéger des français ça veut
dire des masques et des tests il faut
arrêter maintenant nous mentir arrêté de
tourner autour du pot
le gouvernement n'a pas été capable de
le faire il ne l'est toujours pas il
faut accélérer là dessus deuxièmement
deuxièmement il faut protéger en avant
nos frontières et troisièmement protéger
nos enfants en le faisant rentrer à
l'école qu'en septembre
voilà les premiers gestes à faire à part
ça c'est de la littérature
alexis belge fait quelques secondes pour
conclure non mais écoutez je pense que
aujourd'hui on sait il ya des choses
qu'on maîtrise
il faut respecter les gestes barrière il
faut équiper les gens en masse qu il
faut augmenter le nombre de tests
ça c'est des choses qui doivent être
faites le plus rapidement possible ça
aurait dû être fait avant mais bon
aujourd'hui on sait que ça doit être
fait et puis pour le reste il va pour le
reste je pense qu'il faudra qu'on vivent
avec une épée de damoclès autour de
notre tête c'est le risque d'une
deuxième vague d'une part et d'autre
part le fait d'être obligé de continuer
à respecter un certain nombre de règles
pour limiter au maximum la contagion et
les victimes faut le rappeler quand même
que on est un déjà près de 25 mille
morts et ça n'est malheureusement pas
encore terminée merci
il beaucoup messieurs d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france alexis
bachelet et ex députée ps des
hauts-de-seine et et conseiller
municipal de la ville de colombes avec
vous laurent jacobellis porte parole du
rassemblement national